the landmark treaty protecting women
from violence
bears the name of turkey's largest city
now in istanbul there's anger that
turkey is walking away from the accord
it was first to sign a decade ago
i wasn't feeling safe as a woman even
before this and after this i feel like
i'm in an
unsafe environment at least there was a
law a decision that i was leaning on
but now i feel like i don't have any
support i feel vulnerable
in 2011 more than 45 governments
promised to take tougher action on
domestic violence
marital rape and female genital
mutilation
but conservative groups and officials
from the governing act party
have long argued it's inconsistent with
turkey's values
and undermines the traditional family
unit
recep tayyip erdogan ordered his
country's withdrawal in a presidential
decree
the government says turkey's laws are
enough to protect women and their rights
but not everyone agrees
every day women are killed in the street
in the bus
in the car there are women who are
beaten by their lovers in an elevator
when you go to the police they say it's
okay he's your husband
forgive him for the sake of your
children but when that woman returns
home
the same police officers go there a day
after to take her to her funeral
how are they protecting us rights groups
say violence against women
and deaths are on the rise in turkey
there has been an increase in femicide
cases
last year only last year 300 women were
killed
170 cases were unidentified
so women are saying well
investigate why did we are being killed
why there is an increasing violence
turkey is not alone in turning its back
on the istanbul convention
conservative and populist governments in
hungary poland
slovakia and bulgaria have all moved to
prevent the accord from being ratified
when you have a situation where people
in charge think they can
score political points by withdrawing
even
nominal protections for women and
vulnerable populations you have a
situation where people who would like to
target them
believe they can do so without any sort
of penalty
protesters like these in istanbul say
they'll fight on
insisting their years-long struggle
won't be erased by the stroke of a pen
[Music]
alexandra byers al jazeera